[Music]
we begin in the United States where the
White House and Republicans have agreed
in principle to raise the debt ceiling
after weeks of negotiations Kevin
McCarthy and President Joe Biden made
the deal days before an expected default
it increases the amount the government
can borrow but Cuts federal spending the
U.S treasury Department had warned that
the government could run out of money to
pay its bills if Congress didn't act by
June the 5th
after weeks of negotiations we have come
to an agreement in principle we still
have a lot of work to do but I believe
this is an agreement in principle that's
worthy of the American people
it has historic reductions in spending
consequential reforms that will lift
people out of poverty into the workforce
reign in government overreach there are
no new taxes no new government programs
there's a lot more within the bill we
still have more work to do tonight to
finish all the writing of it
but for more on this now let's cross
over to Mike Hannah who's in Washington
DC so Mike an agreement in principle
what do they actually mean by this
is indeed well the agreement was reached
finally it seems in a 90-minute
telephone conversation between the
president and the speaker of the house
and there have been compromises on both
sides it would appear the Biden
Administration has agreed to keep
government spending flat over the next
year and increase it by no more than one
percent in 2025 the agreement is in
place for two years which means it will
take the country past the 2024 election
now Republicans would be able to argue
that they have slashed government
spending Democrats will be able to argue
that they have protected many social
programs however there's going to be a
real struggle to get the legislation
through Congress where there's still a
division where there is still antipathy
to the reports of what this deal
actually looks like but Mike does this
mean the crisis is essentially over then
and what happens next
no because it has to go through Congress
and you are going to have Hardline
Republicans arguing that the cuts are
too modest you will have Progressive
Democrats arguing that the cuts are too
stringent now it's going to be up to the
speaker of the house and the minority
leader in the house to get the votes
together to pass this legislation that
means that Republicans and Democrats are
going to have to vote together given the
slim majority that exists within the
house and indeed within the Senate this
is going to be a really tough task for
the Congress leaders to persuade the
rank and file to vote in favor of this
legislation but the house Speaker
appears adamant that he will get the
votes required he says that the vote
will take place on Wednesday and it will
go he says to the president for
signature
Mike thanks very much indeed for that
update